we must ensure delivery of vaccines from
the companies
and we must ensure the quick and
efficient use of the available vaccines
i am glad that we agreed with member
states to administer
as many doses as possible over the next
weeks and months
of course to support this we are working
hand-in-hand with
emma and the companies we are determined
to provide
more predictability and stability to the
delivery process
and we look forward to more vaccines
and more doses coming on stream soon
at the same time we are increasingly
concerned about
different variants of the virus thus we
need
much better knowledge of the real
presence and the real spread of these
variants of the virus and all the
different places in the european union
and that is why we need more testing
and more sequencing after positive
testing
throughout the entire european union
indeed in order to keep our external and
internal borders open we need
targeted measures that keep us all safe
so we propose that the newly introduced
category of dark red
a dark red zone would show that in this
zone the virus is circulating at a very
high level
persons traveling from dark red
areas could be required to do a test
before departure
as well as to undergo quarantine after
arrival this is
within the european union and in view of
the very serious health
situation all non-essential travel
should be strongly discouraged both
within the country and of course across
borders
at the same time it is absolutely
important to keep the single market
functioning